all right
just slowly back up there's a door
behind us we just have to get outside
and call the nine-nine
they're stealing the exits oh my god
it's real life die hard
i mean oh no crime
this better be an emergency there better
be a gun to your head charles gina and i
are in a hostage situation oh god
i shouldn't have said the gun thing
terry regrets the way he answered the
phone we're
good ones there are multiple gunmen
they've blocked all the exits they've
taken the security guards hostage and
we're looking for a place to hide
it's awesome awesome awesomely serious
i am not enjoying this no matter how
much it is 100 my favorite movie come to
life
stay here with him i do some recon wait
shouldn't we all stick together someone
has to assess the situation boyle plus
we're trapped
on christmas with a bunch of bad guys
who are very likely german
this is my john mcclane moment okay
you're gonna need a tank top he could
have mine no need i snagged this on the
way here
baby girl yeah they didn't have the best
selection i'll probably just skip the
tank yeah i will return
okay gina
all right let's see what we're dealing
with
i'll call you klaus
you will be gutter with the little dots
over the you
hey matt are you in position i'm here
oh great the bad guy's name is matt
hey sorry that took so long gina you
doing okay you scared
i'm scared you won't let me make a
flamethrower and use it to throw flame
you're right i will not do that you're
gonna stay here and keep hiding boyle
and i are gonna handle this
here's the situation 12 terrorists one
cop just the way he likes it who's he
me why are you calling yourself he
because that's the tagline from the die
hard poster and also my high school
yearbook quote
all right you know i recognize it next
time lead with that right sorry
all right where are you holding the
hostages i bet you'd like to know
canadian no you're so clearly supposed
to be german
are any of you german
how are we gonna get past some of that
gunfight tell you how john mcclane would
do it
the vents ah blast the ac they get
chilly they leave to find sweaters
no we're gonna climb through them even
better classic use events
so you're a cop
i hate cops they gave me this
nice finally a good bad guy this dude
gets it
now i'm going to kill you okay you took
it a little too far maybe scale it back
scotch
all the buckets boyle you did it and you
completely botched the catchphrase
i'm pretty sure it was right no but you
did great come on
come on oh no i broke the hotel key i
forgot was in my wallet for the last
five years where's rosa
we can't wait for her the exam's in 20
minutes it's my fault we're up here
i just won't take the test i'll wait
three years for the next one
oh no you won't no jake
you are not die-harding off this room i
am definitely die-harding off
this roof for you and only for you and
also for me because i've always wanted
to do it
okay come on get down from there it's
too dangerous it's perfectly safe
see you in hell kiddo what
oh are there bars on the window yeah
they're bars on the way now
[Music]
where are you guys what the hell is
taking you so long
did jake die hard off the roof yeah but
the windows have bars yeah
we all know about the bars rosa all
right you get to the exam i'll take care
of jake
yeah don't worry about me the important
thing is you go become a sergeant
leave me i know it's gonna be hard to
walk away but you have to be strong
she left like two minutes ago you're
talking to nobody yeah that makes sense
my god he's beautiful oh jake
he's got your face charles meet mac
short for mclean i said surely i love it
no as in john from die hard i mean
they're both incredibly cool
only one oscar winner
you